For most of us, the idea of jumping off a bridge with a parachute or surfing a wave 70 feet high seems to defy comprehension. We might regard base jumpers, big wave surfers, free solo rock climbers, and other extreme adventurers with a mixture of confusion, awe, and skepticism, thinking there's no way I could risk my life like that. Psychologists too have wondered what drives people to participate in extreme sports, and they're finding that many of our preconceived notions about adventurers are wrong. Many extreme adventurers, they argue, are not dare-devil risk-takers, but instead careful planners who prepare methodically for the adventures they undertake. So what does draw people to extreme adventure? Do adventurers share any common personality traits? Do they just
对于我们大多数人来说，从桥上跳下或冲浪70英尺高的巨浪，这种想法似乎令人难以理解。我们可能会以一种困惑、敬畏和怀疑的混合心态来看待低空跳伞者、巨浪冲浪者、徒手攀岩者和其他极限冒险家，心想我绝不可能那样拿自己的生命去冒险。心理学家也一直想知道是什么驱动人们参与极限运动，他们发现我们对冒险家许多先入为主的观念是错误的。他们认为，许多极限冒险家并非鲁莽的冒险者，而是细致的规划者，他们会为自己所从事的冒险活动进行有条不紊的准备。那么，究竟是什么吸引人们进行极限冒险呢？冒险家们是否拥有共同的人格特质？他们只是
have less fear than the rest of us, or do they channel their fear differently? And what role does fear play in how adventurers approach what they do? What lessons can less adventurous people learn from research into extreme adventure? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Eric Breimer, a psychologist and senior lecturer at Southern Cross University in Australia, where he studied.
比我们其他人更少恐惧，还是他们以不同的方式引导自己的恐惧？恐惧在冒险家处理他们所做的事情时扮演了什么角色？不太爱冒险的人能从极限冒险的研究中学到什么？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是埃里克·布雷默博士，他是澳大利亚南十字星大学的心理学家和高级讲师，他在那里研究
the human nature relationship and performance in extreme environments. He has interviewed dozens of adventurers for his research studies and is the editor of a recent book, Adventure Psychology, going knowingly into the unknown. Dr. Breimer, thank you for joining me today. Thank you very much for inviting me, Kim. It's very wonderful to be with you across the pond. The big pond. The very big pond. Well, let's start with a question that I posed in the introduction. What draws people to participate in activities like base jumping or free solo climbing? I mean, you've interviewed a lot of adventurers over the years. What have they told you about why they do what they do?
人与自然的各种关系以及在极端环境下的表现。他为自己的研究采访了数十位冒险家，并且是近期出版的《冒险心理学：清醒地进入未知》一书的编辑。布雷默博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。非常感谢您的邀请，金。能跨越大洋与您交流真是太棒了。那片大洋。那片非常大的大洋。好吧，让我们从我在介绍中提出的一个问题开始。是什么吸引人们参与像低空跳伞或徒手攀岩这样的活动？我的意思是，多年来您采访了许多冒险家。他们告诉过您为什么要做他们所做的事情吗？
Yeah, that's a fascinating question because there's actually there's two parts to that question. One is why do people start? And the other one is why do people continue? And they're often very different. So the traditional notion is the no fear, risk-taking, the kind of death-wish notion where people get into these things because they just love to take risks. They've got a personality that drives them to look at these kind of activities. But actually we find it's very different to that. The reason people start is as varied as there are people there.
是的，这是一个引人入胜的问题，因为这个问题实际上包含两个部分。一个是人们为什么开始？另一个是人们为什么坚持？它们通常非常不同。传统的观念是无所畏惧、冒险、那种死亡愿望的观念，即人们参与这些活动是因为他们就是喜欢冒险。他们拥有一种驱动他们去寻找这类活动的人格。但实际上我们发现情况大不相同。人们开始的原因和人一样多种多样。
I've spoken to some people who said, well, you know, my family has surfers, so I got into surfing. But they were the only one that went into big wave surfing. I've spoken to people who said, I didn't think I was interested in any of this. I can remember talking to one lady for sake of example who called herself a corporate chick. And she said, only when I went to a corporate motivational talk. And I saw this person was describing their life and they had images of some base jumping because they were a base jumper. They were also a medical doctor as well, but they were a base jumper. And she said something just clicked inside of me.
我曾与一些人交谈过，他们说，你知道，我的家人里有冲浪者，所以我开始冲浪。但他们是家里唯一一个从事巨浪冲浪的人。我曾与一些人交谈过，他们说，我原以为我对这些都不感兴趣。我记得曾采访过一位女士，举个例子，她自称是“职场女性”。她说，直到我去参加了一场企业励志讲座。我看到那个人在描述他们的生活，他们展示了一些低空跳伞的图片，因为他们是一名低空跳伞者。他们也是一名医生，但他们是一名低空跳伞者。她说内心有什么东西被触动了。
And I thought that looks fascinating. And then she spent six, seven years learning everything she needed to learn in order to start to base jump. I can, so there's all sorts of varieties of reasons why people get into it. And believe it or not, some people get into it because they love the idea of safety and managing sort of, you know, the base jumping association in Australia, for sake of example, has a safety officer. So there are all sorts of reasons.
我想那看起来太迷人了。然后她花了六七年时间学习她需要学习的一切，以便开始进行低空跳伞。所以我说，人们参与其中的原因多种多样。信不信由你，有些人参与其中是因为他们喜欢安全和管理的概念，例如，澳大利亚低空跳伞协会就有一名安全官员。所以原因各种各样。
And most of those reasons are individual. They're based on people's particular life at the time, what comes their way. It's not always, there is a kind of framework out there that suggests that their opportunities in their particular environment because they have a personality that just go and do it. But we also find that's not quite true either. I've spoken to people who were born and bred and bought up in a city. But one particular person said, ever since he can remember, he was just really fascinated by stories of the mountains. And he used to read mountain stories, mountaineering stories, all those sort of things. Soon he was old enough, he moved to the mountain areas and started to learn how to climb and mountaineer and all those sort of things when he could do that in his own.
而且大多数原因是个人的。它们基于人们当时特定的生活，以及他们所遇到的事情。这并不总是，虽然有一种框架认为，因为他们拥有那种说干就干的人格，所以他们在特定的环境中拥有机会。但我们也发现这并不完全正确。我曾与一些在城市出生、长大的人交谈过。但有一个人说，从他记事起，他就对山的故事非常着迷。他过去常读山的故事、登山故事，所有这些东西。一旦他长大了，他就搬到了山区，并开始学习如何攀登和登山，以及所有他能做的事情。
I've spoken to people who lived in the middle of Australia that just had this kind of connection or fascination with the surf. As soon as they were old enough, as soon as they could, they moved to the coast to start developing skills and activities within surfing. So why people get into it is, you know, it's a personal thing. And I'll be honest, there are actually some people get into it because they see these videos on YouTube. They hear this heavy rock music and they think this is exciting and thrilling. I'll get into that and I'll give that a go. But often what happens with those people is either they very quickly realize it's not quite as simple as they thought originally. It actually takes a lot of commitment and hard work and training, et cetera, to do this well.
我曾与住在澳大利亚中部的人交谈过，他们对冲浪有一种联系或迷恋。一旦他们长大了，一旦他们能够，他们就搬到了海岸，开始在冲浪中发展技能和活动。所以人们为什么参与其中，你知道，这是一件私人的事情。老实说，确实有些人参与其中是因为他们在YouTube上看到了这些视频。他们听到这种重金属摇滚音乐，他们认为这很刺激、很惊险。我会参与其中，我会试一试。但这些人的情况往往是，他们很快意识到这并不像他们最初想的那么简单。要做好这件事，实际上需要大量的投入、努力工作和训练等等。
Or if they're lucky, they have an accident, which means they can't do it anymore. But often they die and then they just can't continue. So they drop out pretty quickly. So that brings us on to the next element is why people continue. And that's the really fascinating question. Because what we're definitely finding is the idea of the traditional idea of no fear, having a death wish, having a risk taking or a type of personality doesn't fit the extreme sports athlete. In fact, we find they're very careful.
或者如果他们幸运的话，他们会发生事故，这意味着他们不能再做了。但通常他们会死亡，然后他们就无法继续了。所以这把我们带到了下一个要素，即人们为什么坚持。这是一个非常引人入胜的问题。因为我们绝对发现，传统的无所畏惧、有死亡愿望、有冒险人格的观念并不适合极限运动运动员。事实上，我们发现他们非常谨慎。
We find that in fact they have an in-depth knowledge of the environment that they are participating in. we find that actually it takes years and they do some really intense training to get to the skills. One base jump for sake of example before they started proximity flying. And for those who don't know, proximity flying is when you jump off a cliff, but you have a wingsuit and then you fly along the cliff as far as you can and travel for a distance before you pull your parachute. But before he transitioned from base jumping to wingsuit, he spent years researching across the world every single potential accident in order to figure out whether there were patterns. And then he did find patterns.
我们发现，事实上，他们对自己所参与的环境有深入的了解。我们发现，实际上这需要数年时间，他们会进行一些非常强烈的训练来获得技能。以一名低空跳伞者为例，在他们开始近距离飞行之前。对于那些不知道的人，近距离飞行是指你从悬崖上跳下，但你穿着翼装，然后你沿着悬崖尽可能远地飞行，在拉开降落伞之前飞行一段距离。但在他从低空跳伞过渡到翼装飞行之前，他花了数年时间研究世界各地每一个潜在的事故，以找出是否存在模式。然后他确实发现了模式。
And he decided, well, okay, these are the patterns where things go wrong. I'm going to avoid those. And this is not an unusual kind of activity at all. So people really get to profound, not only the environment, but profound knowledge of the activity they're doing. The other thing that happens as well, and people start at different levels here, is that because extreme sports athletes are basically on their own, if something goes wrong in the middle of an extreme sport activity, nobody can help you out.
他决定，好吧，好的，这些是事情出错的模式。我要避免这些。这根本不是一种不寻常的活动。所以人们确实对环境，不仅是环境，而且对他们所做的活动有了深刻的了解。另一件也会发生的事情，而且人们在不同的水平上开始，是因为极限运动运动员基本上是独自一人的，如果极限运动活动中途出了问题，没有人能帮你。
The only person that's there for you is yourself. So you have to have a really profound, deep knowledge of your capacities, of what you're capable of and how you're feeling and all those sort of things. Because if you're not feeling right, if things aren't quite right or you have the sense that something is not right, it might just be the winds in the wrong direction or something isn't sort of feeling well. You have to have the capacity to say, well, actually, you know what? I'm going to walk away.
那里唯一能为你提供帮助的人就是你自己。所以你必须对自己有非常深刻、透彻的了解，了解自己的能力，了解自己能做什么，了解自己的感受以及所有这些事情。因为如果你感觉不对劲，如果事情不太对劲，或者你感觉到有什么不对劲，可能只是风向不对，或者有什么感觉不太好。你必须有能力说，好吧，实际上，你知道吗？我要走开。
I'll come back again another day because today doesn't feel good. And that happens more than you realize within an extreme sport context as well. And the people that I interviewed weren't in the typical age that we think about extreme athletes as well. I mean, they weren't the sort of older teenagers, younger 20s. The youngest person was just over 30 and the oldest person. was in their 70s, and they were still participating in their particular chosen extreme sport, you know, the ones that they had chosen.
我会改天再来，因为今天感觉不好。在极限运动的背景下，这种情况发生的次数比你想象的要多。而且我采访的人也不是我们认为的极限运动员的典型年龄。我的意思是，他们不是那种年龄较大的青少年或20出头的年轻人。最年轻的人刚过30岁，而最年长的人已经70多岁了，他们仍然在参与他们选择的极限运动，你知道，他们所选择的那些。
The last element of this is because of that requirement of the in-depth knowledge of the environment, we often find that extreme athletes, they're not people that go out and, you know, how can I demonstrate my risk-taking activity here today? Oh, look, there's a, I'll just grab a mountain bike and try and do this, or I'll grab this, or they're very focused in the activity because they learn so much about it. is very rare to find that people do more than one activity. Or if they do, it's because they need the skills to, say, climb a mountain in order to jump off if they're a base jumper. So they need a certain element of skills to get to the particular place.
这最后一个要素是因为需要对环境有深入的了解，我们经常发现极限运动员，他们不是那种走出去，你知道，我今天怎么能在这里展示我的冒险活动？哦，看，有一个，我会抓起一辆山地自行车试着做这个，或者我会抓起这个，或者他们非常专注于活动，因为他们学到了很多关于它的知识。很少有人会做不止一项活动。或者如果他们做了，那是因为他们需要技能，比如，如果他们是低空跳伞者，就需要爬山才能跳下去。所以他们需要一定的技能要素才能到达特定的地方。
But really, their main activity is base jumping. So in a summary, basically, there's two elements of motivations, why people get into it and why people continue. And they're very different. What you're describing is a really interesting level of meticulousness, and I'm wondering whether these people are as meticulous about everything else in their lives. That's a very good question. They are definitely – well, there's two elements to that one as well, unfortunately. One is that doing the adventure and the extreme sport does change your attitude in everyday life as well. and it changes the way you interact with others, the way you experience your relationship with a natural world.
但实际上，他们的主要活动是低空跳伞。所以总结一下，基本上，动机有两个要素，人们为什么开始和人们为什么坚持。它们非常不同。你所描述的是一种非常有趣的细致程度，我想知道这些人是否对他们生活中的其他一切也同样细致。这是一个非常好的问题。他们绝对是——好吧，不幸的是，这一点也有两个要素。一个是进行冒险和极限运动确实改变了你在日常生活中的态度。它改变了你与他人互动的方式，改变了你体验与自然世界关系的方式。
It changes the way you experience everyday activities. For such as example, you may still feel a little bit nervous public speaking if you're not used to it, but people often report utilizing their extreme sports skills to work with that and say, well, in the end, I have these feelings in other places, so I should be able to do this as well. If meticulousness means over, you know, over-cautious, over-specific, over-perfectionist, if you like, then I would say no, because actually life becomes a lot more enjoyable, a lot more fun, a lot more sort of, you know, you're less concerned about some of the minor things that we may, who, you know, not extreme sort of athletes, considered to be very important.
它改变了你体验日常活动的方式。例如，如果你不习惯公开演讲，你可能仍然会感到有点紧张，但人们经常报告说利用他们的极限运动技能来处理这个问题，并说，好吧，最终，我在其他地方也有这些感觉，所以我应该也能做到这一点。如果细致意味着过度谨慎、过度具体、过度完美主义，如果你愿意的话，那么我会说不，因为实际上生活变得更加愉快，更加有趣，更加，你知道，你对我们这些非极限运动员认为非常重要的一些小事不太关心了。
I remember, you know, extreme athletes talking about how they interact with others. And, you know, before I was an adventure, I used to get really concerned when people were really cross with me or really disappointed at where I used to work. Now it doesn't bother me. I just think, well, okay, that's, you know, they're having a bad day. That's their problem, not mine. I remember speaking to a doctor who used to say, I was so concerned, you know, the medical element of what I do and what I was taught, you know, people, in the end, their emergency doctor, you know, People were just numbers and beds. But then he's had a very interesting story how he got into it, but that's for later on, I think.
我记得，你知道，极限运动员谈论他们如何与他人互动。而且，你知道，在我成为冒险家之前，当人们对我非常生气或对我工作的地方非常失望时，我过去常常感到非常担心。现在这对我没有困扰。我只是想，好吧，好的，那是，你知道，他们度过了糟糕的一天。那是他们的问题，不是我的。我记得曾与一位医生交谈过，他过去常说，我非常担心，你知道，我所做的医疗要素以及我被教导的东西，你知道，人们，最终，他们的急诊医生，你知道，人们只是床上的数字。但他有一个非常有趣的故事，关于他是如何进入这个领域的，但我认为那是以后的事了。
But he said as a result of getting into adventure and becoming a stream athlete, he now realizes that actually there's Mr. and Mrs. So-and-so in the bed. And not only that, but they have all these other things going on in the life. And they have a family and they have a place that they live. And maybe they have pets. So the perspective changes. Life becomes much more enjoyable, much more fulfilling. as a result of participating extreme sports because it's that existential notion, you know.
但他表示，由于进入冒险领域并成为极限运动员，他现在意识到实际上床上躺着的是某某先生和某某太太。不仅如此，他们的生活中还有所有这些其他的事情在发生。他们有家庭，他们有居住的地方。也许他们有宠物。所以视角改变了。生活变得更加愉快，更加充实。作为参与极限运动的结果，因为这就是那种存在主义的概念，你知道。
You realize how close you are to death and then everything else doesn't matter as much as you thought it did. Yeah, it sounds almost mystical, you know, in that sense. It very much is and people often report things that, you know, there have been some extreme sport athletes who have been trying for years and years through mindfulness meditation to get to a point of freedom and they've got it pretty instantly through extreme sports, but not through mindfulness meditation.
你意识到你离死亡有多近，然后其他一切都不像你想象的那么重要了。是的，这听起来几乎是神秘的，你知道，从这个意义上说。它确实非常神秘，人们经常报告说，你知道，有一些极限运动运动员多年来一直试图通过正念冥想达到自由的境界，而他们通过极限运动相当快地得到了它，而不是通过正念冥想。
There are parts of the experience. that I could only describe as ineffable. There are senses of freedom. There are senses of floating, flying, time standing still. You know, sensory capacities expanding so you can see things and hear things much clearer whilst you're doing, you know, involved in those sports than you can in everyday life. So I mentioned in the intro some of the different extreme sports that you study. I'm wondering what counts as an extreme sport?
体验中有一些部分。我只能用不可言喻来形容。有自由的感觉。有漂浮、飞翔、时间静止的感觉。你知道，感官能力在扩展，所以当你参与这些运动时，你可以比在日常生活中更清晰地看到和听到事物。所以我刚才在介绍中提到了你研究的一些不同的极限运动。我想知道什么算作极限运动？
Why is base jumping is an extreme sport, but something like... I don't know, basketball is not. So that was probably the major challenge when I first got involved in looking at extreme sports athletes. And that was because research up to the time I started had not made that clear. So they would use the notion of kayaking or they would use the notion of mountaineering. But actually when you dig very closely into it, there's a big difference between kayaking on flat water and kayaking in grade 6. flat water, you get a bit wet and maybe, you know, you get a bit cold depending where you are. If you come out of your boat, if things go wrong, grade six if things go wrong, then you are, the chances are you'll die.
为什么低空跳伞是极限运动，而像……我不知道，篮球却不是。所以这可能是我刚开始参与研究极限运动运动员时面临的主要挑战。这是因为在我开始研究之前，研究还没有明确这一点。所以他们会使用皮划艇的概念，或者他们会使用登山的概念。但实际上当你非常仔细地挖掘它时，在平水上划皮划艇和在6级水域划皮划艇有很大的区别。平水，你会弄湿一点，也许，你知道，你会感到有点冷，取决于你在哪里。如果你从船里出来，如果事情出了问题，6级水域如果事情出了问题，那么你，很有可能你会死。
So one of the things that I did was to say, well, okay, exactly the question you asked me, what makes an extreme sport's an extreme sport? And so the first thing we looked at is if you take this as a continuum, the first thing is that they're interacting in the natural world. So the activity takes place in the natural world. So that means the environment is not so constrained as a basketball environment or a cricket environment or something. So the environment is free. There aren't lines and regulations to say this is in and that is out, which is really important because that's part of the decision-making process, a problem-solving process. The second one is potential outcomes or the most likely outcome if things go wrong is that you're dead. You're lucky if you get seriously injured and people have been lucky.
所以我做的事情之一就是说，好吧，好的，正是你问我的问题，什么使极限运动成为极限运动？所以我们看的第一件事是，如果你把这看作一个连续体，第一件事是他们正在与自然世界互动。所以活动发生在自然世界中。这意味着环境不像篮球环境或板球环境或其他什么那样受到限制。所以环境是自由的。没有界限和规定来说明这是在里面还是在外面，这非常重要，因为这是决策过程、解决问题过程的一部分。第二个是潜在的结果，或者如果事情出错，最可能的结果是你死了。如果你受了重伤，那你很幸运，而且人们确实很幸运。
But the most likely outcome if things go wrong and you haven't been able to resolve it quickly is that you die. And that's unlikely to happen in basketball. I remember one participant saying, you know, they were describing the difference between something like actually they use basketball because they were from the US and their particular extreme sport. And they said, you imagine every time you've missed a goal in basketball, somebody shot you in the head. That's the difference between extreme sports and basketball. So basketball can be extreme, but perhaps we don't want to play that game because we'd end up with a lot of accidents and a lot of dead basketball players. The last element, which is really, very important is that they're independent activities in the sense that they are self-directed. You can't undertake an extreme sport as what we understand as a teamwork activity, or it's very difficult to do that.
但如果事情出错，而你又没能迅速解决，最可能的结果就是死亡。这在篮球运动中是不太可能发生的。我记得有一位参与者说，他们描述了篮球与他们所从事的极限运动之间的区别，因为他们来自美国。他们说，想象一下，每次你在篮球比赛中投失一球，就有人朝你的脑袋开一枪。这就是极限运动和篮球的区别。所以篮球也可以很极限，但也许我们不想玩那种游戏，因为那样会导致很多事故，也会有很多篮球运动员丧生。最后一个非常重要的要素是，它们是独立的活动，因为它们是自我导向的。你无法以我们所理解的团队合作方式进行极限运动，或者说这非常困难。
Because in the end, most extreme sports are, whilst you might have colleagues with you and once you make the jump in a base jump or once you get on the wave and a big wave surf or once you decide to go over that waterfall, you are on your own. Some people tend to think of those who participate in these kinds of sports as adrenaline junkies. In other words, they have something that's akin to an addiction. Is that notion accurate? The notion of addiction is really interesting. get down that pathway. I'm sure that's for another day. But if we take the addiction as something that is harmful to you, something that actually is bad for you, ends up with a, ends up sort of damaging some way, then most definitely not, unless things go wrong, of course, because actually
因为归根结底，大多数极限运动都是如此。虽然你身边可能有同伴，但一旦你在定点跳伞中跳下，或者一旦你踏上巨浪冲浪，或者一旦你决定翻越那个瀑布，你就只能靠自己了。有些人倾向于认为这些运动的参与者是“肾上腺素瘾君子”。换句话说，他们有一种类似于成瘾的东西。这种说法准确吗？关于成瘾的概念确实很有趣。我肯定那又是另一个话题了。但如果我们把成瘾视为对你有害的东西，即实际上对你不利、最终以某种方式造成损害的东西，那么绝对不是，除非事情出了差错，当然，因为实际上
what we find is for most participants, the reason they continue is because they get something so powerfully transformational and beneficial from it. That is akin to flourishing, thriving, is akin to all those kind of mystical things that people search for. That's why they can keep going because it's that sort of element of it. If we consider it in terms of something about it that drives you to continue doing it, then again, it's not a negative concept that drives you to continue doing it. It's that more positive element, the sort of the more flourishing, thriving, high levels of well-being, the feelings of freedom, flying, the kind of ineffable, all those sort of things
我们发现对于大多数参与者来说，他们继续下去的原因是他们从中获得了如此强大、具有变革性且有益的东西。这类似于蓬勃发展、茁壮成长，类似于人们所追求的那些神秘事物。这就是他们能够坚持下去的原因，因为这就是其中的那种要素。如果我们从某种驱使你继续做某事的东西的角度来看，那么它同样不是一个驱使你继续下去的负面概念。它是那种更积极的要素，那种蓬勃发展、茁壮成长、高水平的幸福感、自由飞翔的感觉，那种难以言表的感觉，所有这些东西
that provides the opportunity to keep going. The other element which really indicates that it's not akin to an addiction is that we find that extreme athletes are really keen to give back. They're really keen to work for the environment that they participate in. So we have extreme athletes, world-renowned stream athletes, who travel the world defending and trying to talk about the oceans and how we should be protecting them and looking after them. or we have extreme skiers going around the world looking at, you know, trying to get people to think more carefully about climate change because of what's happening to the environment in the mountains.
提供了继续前进的机会。另一个真正表明它与成瘾无关的要素是，我们发现极限运动员非常热衷于回馈社会。他们非常热衷于为他们所参与的环境工作。所以我们有世界知名的极限运动员，他们周游世界，捍卫并试图谈论海洋，以及我们应该如何保护和照顾它们。或者我们有极限滑雪者环游世界，试图让人们更仔细地思考气候变化，因为山区环境正在发生变化。
So actually what we get is a really positive outcome from it. I mean, if we say that mindfulness-based work, or if we say that those sort of things are addictive, then because they're really positive and powerful and people want to keep doing them, then perhaps there's some similarity between addiction. But where we are at the moment, the indications are definitely not. Are there parallels between people who pursue extreme sports and people who pursue other types of extreme experiences, such as being a war correspondent or a Navy SEAL or even a spy? Yeah, that's a really interesting question. I haven't researched spies and things like that, so I don't know. If anybody is out there who is a spy who would like to be part of a research project, please let me know. But if we look at a comparison between people who do extreme sport and people who do those
所以实际上我们从中得到的是一个非常积极的结果。我的意思是，如果我们说基于正念的工作，或者如果我们说那些事情是令人上瘾的，那么因为它们非常积极和强大，人们想要继续做它们，那么也许成瘾之间有一些相似之处。但就目前而言，迹象绝对不是这样。追求极限运动的人与追求其他类型极限体验的人（例如战地记者、海豹突击队队员甚至间谍）之间是否存在相似之处？是的，这是一个非常有趣的问题。我没有研究过间谍之类的人，所以我不知道。如果外面有任何间谍愿意参与研究项目，请告诉我。但如果我们比较极限运动参与者和那些
other activities, there are some differences in the sense that an extreme sport is generally speaking a leisure-based activity. It's something that people do. If you're lucky, you get sponsored to do these sort of things. But for most people, it's something they do in their own time. And they earn their living. They do the day-to-day stuff in a different way. So they aren't linked.
其他活动参与者，确实存在一些差异，因为极限运动通常是一种基于休闲的活动。这是人们做的事情。如果你幸运的话，你会因为做这些事情而获得赞助。但对大多数人来说，这是他们在业余时间做的事情。他们靠其他方式谋生，做日常工作。所以它们并不相关。
They aren't combined. There's no necessity to do it. There's nobody saying, by the way, your job is to do this as in a Navy SEAL or your job is to do this as in a spy. There isn't any of those outside forces that come into it that to indicate that this is something that they almost need to do because it's part of their work, part of what they're supposed to do. So that separates the two already. The second element is that there was some research some time ago that tried to use psychodynamic theory and explain. extreme diving through psychodynamic theory. I think they did a very good job at explaining why some people might do extreme diving, but actually it didn't really do a good job of why everybody
它们并不结合。没有必要去做。没有人说，顺便说一句，你的工作是做这个，就像海豹突击队队员那样，或者你的工作是做这个，就像间谍那样。没有任何外部力量介入，表明这是他们几乎必须做的事情，因为这是他们工作的一部分，是他们应该做的事情的一部分。所以这已经将两者分开了。第二个要素是，前段时间有一些研究试图使用心理动力学理论来解释极限潜水。我认为他们在解释为什么有些人可能会进行极限潜水方面做得很好，但实际上它并没有很好地解释为什么每个人
does it. And there are definitely people who get involved who might have particular issues outside and they want to kind of do these things, but that's a very small percentage of people that get involved. So I think the short answer to that is no. And for all sorts of different reasons, One is, for sake of example, if we take the personality argument, you know, you've got to have a different kind of personality to become a Navy SEAL or to become a spy or whatever it might be. And I'd say I'm not an expert in those areas at all, so I'm hoping I'm not commenting, you know, in a way that's sort of derogatory to them. But we find within extreme sport, there's such a range of personality structures from the Big Five to all sorts of other personality, the sensation seeking ones, etc. that participate in extreme sports, it's impossible to say that this kind of personality
都会这样做。确实有一些参与者可能在外部有特定的问题，他们想做这些事情，但这只是参与者中很小的一部分。所以我认为简短的回答是不。出于各种不同的原因，例如，如果我们以人格论点为例，你知道，你必须具备不同的人格才能成为海豹突击队队员或间谍或其他什么。我想说我根本不是这些领域的专家，所以我希望我的评论不会以贬低他们的方式进行。但我们在极限运动中发现，参与极限运动的人格结构范围非常广，从“大五人格”到各种其他人格，如寻求刺激的人格等，不可能说这种人格
is the kind of personality that will work in extreme sports. It's probably easy to say that if something goes wrong, you may be likely to be a personality or type, but not to participate, not to do things well, not to explore what an extreme sport can offer. So there's all sorts of indications that actually participate in extreme sport is not similar to some other activities where things might be dangerous or they might be, you know, require a particular way of behaving.
是适合极限运动的人格。如果出了问题，你可能更容易成为某种人格或类型，但不是为了参与，不是为了把事情做好，不是为了探索极限运动能提供什么。所以有各种迹象表明，实际上参与极限运动与某些其他危险的或可能需要特定行为方式的活动并不相似。
Having said that, there are also things that could be very similar, such as the sense of calm when you're doing something that definitely comes across in extreme sports. And I can imagine as a spy and as a Navy SEAL, etc., you'd need to have a sense of calm in really dangerous situations. If not, things aren't going to go too well for you. and extreme sports athletes have that sense of calm. And perhaps also a sense of vulnerability is probably too strong, but surrendering to the moment. Extreme sports athletes are very much, well, I will control everything I can, but I know in the end I can't control the whole process. So I will do whatever I can to prepare well, to be in contact with myself to make sure I'm feeling okay, to make sure my parachutes packed, my board is appropriate to check the weather, to do all those sort of things around it.
话虽如此，也有一些非常相似的地方，比如当你做某事时的那种平静感，这在极限运动中确实表现得很明显。我可以想象，作为间谍或海豹突击队队员等，在非常危险的情况下，你需要保持冷静。如果不是这样，事情对你来说就不会太顺利。极限运动员就有那种平静感。也许还有一种脆弱感，虽然用这个词可能太强烈了，但那是对当下的臣服。极限运动员非常清楚，好吧，我会控制我能控制的一切，但我知道最终我无法控制整个过程。所以我将尽我所能做好准备，与自己保持联系，确保我感觉良好，确保我的降落伞包好了，我的滑板合适，检查天气，做所有这些相关的事情。
But once I leap, once I make the decision to go, in many ways, I have to just let go. I have to surrender to the moment and be so much so present in that moment that I can interact with that environment so effectively that if things do go wrong for sake of example, I can fix them. Or I can enjoy. I can be, you know, I can be with the environment enough that I can play with it. I can be in a dance with it. I can be working with that environment. And I could imagine that's probably very similar if you're a spy or if you're a Navy SEAL as well.
但一旦我跳下去，一旦我做出决定，在很多方面，我必须放手。我必须臣服于当下，并如此深刻地存在于那一刻，以至于我可以如此有效地与环境互动，如果事情真的出了差错，例如，我可以修复它们。或者我可以享受。我可以，你知道，我可以与环境充分融合，我可以与它一起玩耍。我可以与它共舞。我可以与那个环境一起工作。我想如果是一个间谍或海豹突击队队员，情况可能也非常相似。
You plan what you can. But in the end, the environment also has a role in that, in whatever happens. And therefore, you have to be totally attuned to the information in that environment to make decisions in here and now. And that is very similar, I think, to an extreme sports athlete. Let's talk for a minute about fear. A lot of people might assume that these adventurers are fearless, but you argue that they actually have a lot of fear. And in fact, they need to have fear in order to do what they do.
你计划你能计划的。但最终，环境在发生的一切中也起着作用。因此，你必须完全适应环境中的信息，以便在此时此地做出决定。我认为这与极限运动员非常相似。让我们谈谈恐惧。很多人可能会认为这些冒险家是无所畏惧的，但你认为他们实际上有很多恐惧。事实上，他们需要恐惧才能做他们所做的事情。
Can you explain that? Sure. We're not quite sure of the nuances yet. But broadly, the idea of having no fear, that's the only way you can do that doesn't work in extreme sport context. The reason it doesn't work is because if you have no fear, you're not taking what you're doing. seriously. And if you don't take what you're doing seriously, it means you're not going to pay attention to the real sort of fine information in their environment, to yourself, etc., and it's likely that things will go wrong. So what we actually find is that extreme sports athletes
你能解释一下吗？当然。我们还不完全确定其中的细微差别。但总的来说，没有恐惧的想法，即那是你唯一能做到的方式，这在极限运动背景下是行不通的。它行不通的原因是，如果你没有恐惧，你就没有认真对待你正在做的事情。如果你不认真对待你正在做的事情，这意味着你不会关注环境中真正的细微信息，不会关注你自己等等，事情很可能会出错。所以我们实际上发现的是，极限运动员
take fear seriously, and in fact, fear is really important to them in the sense that it's saying pay attention. When you have that sense of fear, it means you take what you're doing more seriously. You pay attention to all the cues and the information and the environment. You pay attention to how you're feeling. You really make sure that you've done all the preparation, etc. properly. So fear, if you like, is a trigger to pay attention or a facilitator to sort of suggest that you need to take this seriously. This is something if you don't take seriously can go, can be quite disastrous, can be a disastrously wrong. So we find instead that what extreme sports athletes are doing is learning to utilize fear as a way of saying,
认真对待恐惧，事实上，恐惧对他们来说非常重要，因为它在说“注意”。当你有了那种恐惧感时，意味着你更认真地对待你正在做的事情。你关注所有的线索、信息和环境。你关注你的感受。你真的确保你已经正确地完成了所有的准备工作等等。所以恐惧，如果你愿意的话，是一个注意的触发器，或者是一个促进因素，暗示你需要认真对待这件事。如果你不认真对待，这可能会导致灾难性的后果，可能会错得离谱。所以我们发现，极限运动员正在学习利用恐惧作为一种方式，说：
hang on a minute, this feeling I'm getting is suggesting something. What is it that's going on? And it might be for sake of an example, an extreme skier who is in that sort of sense of being present suddenly gets a sensation. They can feel the sensation of fear. And they don't know why to begin with, but maybe the perceptual systems have picked up a bit of a noise or a feeling or a smell or a cool, a haptic kind of. And then they can pay attention to the environment and think, ah, there could be an avalanche and then they know what they need to do. Or a base jumper might do something similar, they might feel the air and think, hang on a minute, I thought it was supposed to be doing this, but this isn't quite right. Something is not happening here, and they might
等一下，我得到的这种感觉暗示着什么。到底发生了什么？举个例子，一个处于那种存在感的极限滑雪者突然有了一种感觉。他们能感觉到恐惧。起初他们不知道为什么，但也许感知系统捕捉到了一点噪音、一种感觉、一种气味或一种凉意、一种触觉。然后他们可以关注环境并想，啊，可能会有雪崩，然后他们就知道他们需要做什么。或者定点跳伞者可能会做类似的事情，他们可能会感觉到空气并想，等一下，我以为它应该是这样的，但这不太对劲。这里有些事情不对劲，他们可能会
realize and they can pay attention. Actually, the air is going a different direction or the wind is going a different direction than I thought it was going. So all those little cues that are facilitated by fear are really, really important. He says, pay attention. This is serious. Do something about it. What we're not quite sure yet is whether the sensation, you know, what happens first, the sensation of fear, obviously, there's an element of the, of picking up something in the environment, and that might be a sensation that comes into the body that says pay attention. But we don't quite know whether it's actual information that says pay attention or whether it's giving you the kind of a bit of a sensation that you then have to look out for information
意识到并开始注意。实际上，空气的流动方向或风向与我预想的不同。所以所有这些由恐惧促进的小线索都非常非常重要。它说，注意。这是严肃的。采取行动。我们还不完全确定是感觉（你知道，什么先发生，恐惧的感觉，显然，有一个捕捉环境中某些东西的要素，那可能是一种进入身体的感觉，说注意）先出现。但我们不太确定它是说“注意”的实际信息，还是它给了你一种感觉，然后你必须去寻找信息
that says pay attention. So that little nuance is not quite there, but it's actually a really important element. I'm wondering if interest in extreme or adventure sports has increased in recent years, or does it just seem that way because we're seeing a lot more coverage of these sorts of things in the media and online. Yes. Yeah, I think we are seeing more, which is definitely good, but actually it has increased as well. A report done by the in the UK, well, there's one done in America, there's one in the UK and there's one done in China too. In the UK, adventure sports are the fastest growing sport. So 55% of people involved in physical activity in sport are doing something
说“注意”。所以那个细微的差别还不完全清楚，但这实际上是一个非常重要的要素。我想知道近年来对极限运动或冒险运动的兴趣是否增加了，还是仅仅因为我们在媒体和网络上看到了更多关于这些事情的报道，所以才显得如此。是的。是的，我认为我们看到的更多了，这绝对是好事，但实际上它确实也增加了。英国的一份报告，嗯，美国有一份，英国有一份，中国也有一份。在英国，冒险运动是增长最快的运动。所以55%参与体育活动的人都在做一些
adventurous. This was maybe four or five years ago. The U.S. has done something similar and they see massive rises in an adventure and more extreme adventures across the U.S. China in a slightly lower level has seen enormous increases in people doing things like mountaineering and hill walking and things like that. Millions of people doing it now and India the same. Partially there's the change is due to the tourism aspect of extreme sports, the more adventure tourism element of it where people can come and have these experiences that may not have the skills and expertise to do it themselves, but they can do something in a context that means there is somebody who is an expert in that area who can manage and, you know, rafting for sake of example,
冒险的事情。这可能是四五年前的事了。美国也做了类似的事情，他们看到整个美国的冒险和更极端的冒险活动大幅上升。中国在稍低的水平上也看到了进行登山、徒步旅行等活动的人数大幅增加。现在有数百万人这样做，印度也是如此。部分原因是这种变化归因于极限运动的旅游方面，即冒险旅游的要素，人们可以来体验这些，他们可能没有技能和专业知识自己去做，但他们可以在一个有专家管理的环境中做一些事情，你知道，例如漂流，
or group bushwalking activities or maybe you go on a three or four day camp or something like that. So those kind of activities are happening. So there's definitely a massive increase across the world, as I say, partially driven by tourism, but also driven by recreational activities, too, people choose and to do it. And that might also be why there are so many people, even though, you know, part of it is to do with the technology, but we see so much more because more people are interested in looking at them and watching them and, you know, and imagining themselves in those contexts or dreaming of the next time they can go away and do that kayak trip or whatever it might be. and I think that's kind of reciprocal thing. The more people do it, the more people are interested, the more they want to see more, and goes on like this. It's a bit of a spiral. It does have a downside.
或者团体丛林徒步活动，或者也许你去参加一个三四天的露营之类的。所以这些活动正在发生。所以世界各地绝对有巨大的增长，正如我所说，部分是由旅游业驱动的，但也由休闲活动驱动，人们选择这样做。这也可能就是为什么有这么多人，即使（你知道，部分原因与技术有关）我们看到更多，因为更多的人有兴趣观看它们，你知道，并想象自己处于那些环境中，或者梦想着下一次他们可以去进行那次皮划艇旅行或其他什么。我认为这是一种互惠的事情。做的人越多，感兴趣的人就越多，他们就越想看更多，如此循环。这有点像螺旋式上升。它确实有负面影响。
All this technology has a downside. And the downside for sake of example is you can watch something that is undertaken by an extreme sport expert. And you don't realize that they spent 10 or 15 years developing the skills to be able to do what they're doing. and you think, oh, that looks interesting and exciting. I can't do that myself. To a certain extent, you can't do the very extreme level yourself because you don't have the skills and expertise and you wouldn't know what to buy and all those sort of things.
所有这些技术都有负面影响。负面影响是，举个例子，你可以观看由极限运动专家进行的活动。你没有意识到他们花了10到15年的时间来发展技能，才能做到他们正在做的事情。你认为，哦，这看起来很有趣和令人兴奋。我自己也能做。在某种程度上，你不能自己达到非常极端的水平，因为你没有技能和专业知识，你也不会知道买什么，所有这些事情。
But it does open up the potential for people doing things that perhaps they don't have the skills and expertise to do. Technology has driven that to an extent. For example, in my activity, whitewater kayaking, the one I prefer to do when I started all boats of fiberglass. So if you bumped in a rock, you'd have a great big hole, then you'd be swimming. Once boats became plastic, you could bump in a rock and it's a bit like a pinball
但它确实为人们做一些他们可能没有技能和专业知识去做的事情打开了潜力。技术在一定程度上推动了这一点。例如，在我的活动中，白水皮划艇，我开始做的时候，所有的船都是玻璃纤维做的。所以如果你撞到岩石，你就会有一个大洞，然后你就得游泳了。一旦船变成了塑料的，你就可以撞到岩石，这有点像弹球
pinball machine. You know, you bump on one rock, you bump on another rock and you bump on another rock and eventually find the way down. So you don't need the skills to do the kind of things that you needed high-level skills to do when I started. So there is that element that we've got to be careful of. But otherwise, I think, it's a really good thing because more people are doing it, more people are interested in seeing these things.
弹球机。你知道，你撞到一块岩石，你撞到另一块岩石，你撞到又一块岩石，最终找到了下去的路。所以你不需要我开始时那种高水平的技能来做那种事情。所以我们必须小心那个要素。但除此之外，我认为这是一件非常好的事情，因为更多的人在做，更多的人有兴趣看到这些事情。
And therefore, that encourages more people to get involved, and hopefully at a level that they can manage and hopefully they develop and get the skills and maybe go on courses to ensure that they understand the dangers, the challenges, all those sort of things of participating in these sports as well. So given the increased interest, do you think that adventure psychology is its own specialty, that it should be recognized as its own specialty, or is it just a part of sports psychology? Yes, that is a really good question. And my feeling is that sport psychology, you know, the difference being sports psychology and adventure psychology is as broad as the difference between sport and clinical and education and organization or clinical and clinical.
因此，这鼓励了更多人参与进来，希望他们能在自己能掌控的水平上参与，并希望他们能有所发展，获得技能，或许还能参加课程，以确保他们了解参与这些运动的危险、挑战以及所有相关事项。那么，考虑到人们兴趣的增加，你认为冒险心理学是一个独立的专业吗？它应该被认可为一个独立的专业，还是仅仅是运动心理学的一部分？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。我的感觉是，运动心理学，你知道，运动心理学和冒险心理学之间的区别，就像运动与临床、教育与组织，或者临床与临床之间的区别一样广泛。
And these are very different notions. The very different notions for a number of reasons. One is that the idea of what an effective outcome is very different. In a sport context, it's about winning and it's about doing that sort of things. that has been translated, let's say, into mountaineering in the terms of conquering Everest. No extreme athletes would consider their conquering Everest. They know full well that A, Everest doesn't even know that they're on the mountain, let alone that's a competition. They also know that if Everest did know that, that they'd snuff them out in a second with the weather conditions.
这些是非常不同的概念。由于多种原因，这些概念截然不同。首先，关于什么是有效结果的理念非常不同。在运动背景下，它是关于获胜，关于做那些事情。这已经被转化，比如说，转化到了登山领域，即征服珠穆朗玛峰。没有极限运动员会认为他们在征服珠穆朗玛峰。他们非常清楚，A，珠穆朗玛峰甚至不知道他们在山上，更不用说这是一场比赛了。他们也知道，如果珠穆朗玛峰真的知道，它会因为天气条件在瞬间将他们消灭。
The other element, of course, is getting to the top of Everest is not the goal. Getting back down again safely is the goal, whereas in a sport context, getting to the top would be considered the goal. So that's one thing. The second element that's really important, as I said earlier on, is the fact that you're participating in environments that are not constrained by white lines, you know, that's in, that's out, and all those kind of things. So there are elements within the environment that you actually have to determine, decide what is an appropriate way to move this environment. There aren't lines that say, no, no, you can't go there because now it's out. And then of course, this most serious element, and there's a few other things as well, but the most serious element is if things do go wrong, it's not a matter of, oh, well, I've lost the game, never mind, we'll train a bit harder next time. You're dead. There isn't a sort of an opportunity for to say, okay, well, I'll come back alive and I'll train a bit harder next time and I'll give it a go next time. You're dead. You don't have that capacity.
当然，另一个因素是，到达珠穆朗玛峰顶并不是目标。安全返回才是目标，而在运动背景下，到达顶峰会被视为目标。所以这是一点。第二个非常重要的因素，正如我之前所说，是你参与的环境不受白线的限制，你知道，那是界内，那是界外，以及所有类似的事情。因此，环境中确实存在一些因素，你必须确定、决定什么是进入这个环境的适当方式。没有界线告诉你，不，不，你不能去那里，因为现在出界了。当然，还有最严重的因素，虽然还有其他一些事情，但最严重的因素是，如果事情真的出了差错，这不是说，哦，好吧，我输了比赛，没关系，下次我们训练刻苦点。你会死。没有机会说，好吧，我会活着回来，下次我会训练得更刻苦，下次再试一次。你会死。你没有那种能力。
So there are very different, very different activities, even though they involve physical activity, even though there's an element of having to, organized, plan, train. In the end, I would say that sport and adventure are as different as sport and clinical. So do you think that people who don't necessarily engage in adventures sports, but do other things, for example, controlled adventures, ziplining or some of these outdoor ropes courses, can they derive some of the same benefits that an actual adventure sports person achieves. I do think so, yes. There are elements that aren't the same, obviously, because you haven't set up the zip
所以它们是非常、非常不同的活动，即使它们涉及身体活动，即使其中包含必须组织、计划、训练的因素。最后，我会说运动和冒险就像运动和临床一样不同。那么你认为那些不一定从事冒险运动，但做其他事情的人，例如受控冒险、高空滑索或一些户外绳索课程，他们能获得与真正的冒险运动者所获得的一些相同的益处吗？我认为可以，是的。显然，有些元素是不一样的，因为你没有设置滑索
line or you may not be an expert in determining how to tie a rope to an ankle if you're going to do a bungee jump or something along those lines. But it still takes an element of knowledge of yourself and trust in yourself. It still takes an element of being able to read the environment to the extent that you can decide whether or not you are actually in the right frame of mind to do this jump. So there's still some element of finding out more about yourself. To an extent there is, but what we're finding very much that there is also a lot of those kind of activities that are very similar to the, you know, to the roller coaster ride in the sense it gives you an element of it, but it doesn't
或者如果你要进行蹦极跳或类似的事情，你可能不是确定如何将绳子系在脚踝上的专家。但它仍然需要对自己的了解和对自己的信任。它仍然需要能够阅读环境，以至于你可以决定你是否真的处于进行这次跳跃的正确心态。所以仍然有一些关于更多地了解自己的元素。在一定程度上是有的，但我们发现很多这类活动与过山车非常相似，因为它给了你一部分体验，但它并没有
give you that depth that you would get from an adventure activity. One other thing to remember also is that in the end, human beings are designed to be a lot of. adventurous. We're not designed to be sedentary. We're not designed to be, you know, to be careful. We're not designed. We've done a fantastic job at designing our environments, let's say, Masler's triangle as a metaphor, to make sure we get, you know, nice water, good health cover, a roof over our head. But the problem is the real essence of human existence has been designed out as a result from us, you know, our societies, our cities, et cetera. And the element at the top of that triangle, that self, you know, the idea where you're kind of getting into flourishing and thriving,
给你从冒险活动中获得的那种深度。还要记住的另一件事是，归根结底，人类被设计成是具有冒险精神的。我们不是被设计成久坐不动的。我们不是被设计成，你知道，小心翼翼的。我们不是被设计成那样的。我们在设计环境方面做得非常出色，比如以马斯洛金字塔作为隐喻，确保我们获得，你知道，干净的水、良好的医疗保障、头顶上的屋顶。但问题是，人类存在的真正本质由于我们的社会、城市等原因被设计掉了。而金字塔顶端的那个自我，你知道，那种你进入繁荣和兴旺的理念，
etc. Is not really designed in those environments. If you look at traditional peoples, the way they lived their life and the way everybody used to live their life was, I wonder what's around the corner, is that noise a saber-toothed tiger, you know, what kind of decisions do I make? What's the environment? So we used to live our lives in relation to the environment in the same way that extreme and adventure athletes do at this moment in time.
等等，在这些环境中并没有真正被设计出来。如果你看看传统民族，他们生活的方式以及每个人过去生活的方式是，我想知道拐角处有什么，那个声音是剑齿虎吗，你知道，我做出什么样的决定？环境是什么？所以我们过去与环境的关系生活，就像极限和冒险运动员现在所做的那样。
So actually adventure is a fundamental element of what it means to be human. Not being adventurous is where the problem is. That's the aspect that we need to think very carefully about, not being adventurous. Of course, our lives are longer now because there is no saber-toothed tiger outside the door. So what are the next big questions that you are looking into as you continue this quest? Yes, so the main area that we're looking at at the moment is we're not at a twice. suggesting that everybody should be a base jumper or a big wave surfer or something along those lines or see it as their life goal to come back down safely from the top of Everest.
所以实际上冒险是作为人类的基本要素。不冒险才是问题所在。这是我们需要非常仔细思考的方面，不冒险。当然，我们的寿命现在更长了，因为门外没有剑齿虎。那么，随着你继续这项探索，你正在研究的下一个大问题是什么？是的，所以我们目前关注的主要领域是，我们并不是建议每个人都应该成为低空跳伞运动员、大浪冲浪者或类似的人，或者把安全从珠穆朗玛峰顶回来作为他们的人生目标。
We're not suggesting that at all. But what we are finding, as I mentioned earlier on, this, because the indications are that adventure is a fundamental human, it's what human beings are meant to be. We wouldn't have got to where we are right now if we weren't adventurous. We wouldn't have, you know, the original human being wouldn't have said, I wonder what's around the corner and we wouldn't have expanded across the world the way we have. And all those sort of things wouldn't have happened if we didn't have an adventurous element in it. And what we're trying to do now is figure out what aspects of adventure are directly linked to well-being and how can we utilize those aspects to support well-being across the globe for people. For sake of example,
我们根本不是这个意思。但正如我之前提到的，我们发现，因为有迹象表明冒险是人类的基本属性，这是人类本该有的样子。如果我们不冒险，我们就不会有今天。我们不会有，你知道，最初的人类不会说，我想知道拐角处有什么，我们就不会像现在这样扩展到全世界。如果我们没有冒险的元素，所有这些事情都不会发生。我们现在试图做的是弄清楚冒险的哪些方面与幸福直接相关，以及我们如何利用这些方面来支持全球人民的幸福。举个例子，
we know and we have known for a long time that physical activity is really good for mental health and well-being. So adventure includes physical activity. So, adventure includes physical activity. So There's an element of that in there. We have known not as long as physical activity, and we're getting a better knowledge of it at the moment. But we are starting, I mean, there's thousands of papers. There's more work to be done, but we're getting a pretty solid understanding of how the natural world, the relationship to human beings and the natural world enhances health and well-being for both planet and people. We're trying to figure out what kind of activities, what kind of environments and all those sort of things.
我们知道，并且长期以来一直知道，身体活动对心理健康和幸福非常有益。所以冒险包括身体活动。所以，冒险包括身体活动。所以，其中有一个元素。我们知道这一点的时间不如身体活动那么长，而且我们目前对它的了解也越来越好。但我们正在开始，我的意思是，有成千上万篇论文。还有更多的工作要做，但我们对自然世界、人类与自然世界的关系如何增强地球和人类的健康与幸福有了相当扎实的了解。我们正在试图弄清楚什么样的活动、什么样的环境以及所有这些事情。
But those two, adventure includes those two. But there's something else in adventure as well. You could argue is more existential, if you like. It could argue that it allows people to experience what human beings are really capable of doing. We call it the form of life, as in there's an element of a way, you know, a kind of way that human beings live their life. What I mean by that is, you know, a monkey form of life and a bird form of life can both live in trees. They both climb trees. They both do all those sort of stuff in trees.
但冒险包括这两者。但冒险中还有其他东西。你可以说它更具存在主义色彩，如果你愿意的话。可以说它让人们体验到人类真正有能力做的事情。我们称之为生命形式，因为有一种生活方式，你知道，一种人类生活的方式。我的意思是，你知道，猴子的生命形式和鸟类的生命形式都可以生活在树上。它们都爬树。它们都在树上做所有那些事情。
But a bird form of life can see as trees. a launch pad to fly. A monkey can't. It might be able to jump, but it can't fly. In the same way, human beings as a form of life have a capacity to experience and live in relation to the world around them, the natural world. We have gradually over the years trimmed that down for all sorts of really good reasons. You know, maybe it started when we started a farm. Maybe it started when industrial revolution came. Maybe it started when we, you know, became more modern societies, is more concerned with health and living longer and all those sort of things. Who knows when he started?
但鸟类的生命形式可以将树木视为起飞的发射台。猴子不能。它也许能跳，但它不能飞。同样，人类作为一种生命形式，有能力体验并与周围的世界、自然世界建立联系。多年来，我们出于各种非常好的原因逐渐削减了这一点。你知道，也许它始于我们开始耕种时。也许它始于工业革命到来时。也许它始于我们，你知道，变得更加现代的社会，更关心健康和长寿以及所有这些事情。谁知道它是什么时候开始的？
But as a result, we've gradually chipped away all these aspects of what it means to be human. That means we aren't really living the human life. That's not to say we suddenly want everybody to die at 20 and we suddenly want everybody to do those sort of things. But then there are elements of adventure in the natural world whilst you're being physically active that actually could enhance people's lives into their 70s, 80s, 90s. A really interesting program on SBS here, which is actually a UK program by a doctor called Michael Mosley. And he started to look in what he called, you know, aging and aging well.
但结果是，我们逐渐削减了作为人类的所有这些方面。这意味着我们并没有真正过着人类的生活。这并不是说我们突然希望每个人都在20岁时死去，也不是说我们突然希望每个人都做那些事情。但自然界中确实存在冒险的元素，当你进行身体活动时，这些元素实际上可以增强人们70岁、80岁、90岁以后的生活。SBS这里有一个非常有趣的节目，实际上是一个由迈克尔·莫斯利医生制作的英国节目。他开始研究他所谓的，你知道，衰老和健康衰老。
And the first program was all about a 79 or 80 year old who was a parachute jumper. And he started in his early 70s. And he's describing how his life has just expanded as a result, you know, and how the sort of things, the way he lives his life has just totally changed and the joy it gets from him. But for others, the idea the adventure might be, I've never played football in my life. You know what? I'm going to set up a local women's football team. And we've had somebody interviewed there and showed how that strengthened her bones.
第一个节目是关于一位79或80岁的跳伞运动员。他在70多岁时开始跳伞。他描述了他的生活是如何因此而扩展的，你知道，以及他生活的方式是如何彻底改变的，以及它带给他的快乐。但对其他人来说，冒险的想法可能是，我这辈子从来没踢过足球。你知道吗？我要组建一支当地的女子足球队。我们采访过一个人，她展示了这如何增强了她的骨骼。
For others, it might be I come from a cultural society where women don't do anything, let alone surf. And there's a lovely surfing organization in Iran and across those sort of things. So there are all sorts of ways that we can tap into adventure. But what we need to ensure is that the way we tap into it is going to enhance that benefit rather than take away from. We don't want to tap into the wrong things. We don't want to tap into the things or you must go base jumping. We want to tap into the things that allow everybody to get the benefits of adventure.
对其他人来说，可能是，我来自一个女性什么都不做的文化社会，更不用说冲浪了。在伊朗和那些地方有一个很棒的冲浪组织。所以我们可以通过各种方式参与冒险。但我们需要确保我们参与的方式将增强这种益处，而不是削弱它。我们不想参与错误的事情。我们不想参与那些，你必须去进行低空跳伞的事情。我们想参与那些让每个人都能获得冒险益处的事情。
And that's the sort of stuff we're working on at the moment. Well, Dr. Brom, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really fascinating. Thank you. It's an absolute pleasure. And thank you very much indeed for inviting me, Kim. You can read more about the psychology of extreme sports in the October issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. Go to our website at www.w.combeckycology.org and look for the links
这就是我们目前正在研究的内容。好吧，布罗姆博士，我要感谢你今天加入我。这真的非常引人入胜。谢谢。这是我的荣幸。也非常感谢你邀请我，金。你可以在美国心理学会杂志《心理学监测》的十月刊中阅读更多关于极限运动心理学的内容。请访问我们的网站 www.apa.org/monitor 并查找链接
on this episode's page. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology there, or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在本集页面上。你也可以在那里，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。